oh what a perfect way to start a cooking
video hi guys I'm back in my kitchen
yeah now with more dog it's almost
Valentine's Day and I decided to make a
cooking video that is dessert base
because so see my Valentine's Day
desserts and drinking are all kind of
associated with each other maybe I'm
forcing the association but you know of
course the ass that's accepted I decided
that I wanted to make a dessert that had
infusions of alcohol today I'm going to
make a mildly Claude Lee that means it's
going to be kind of an apple cobbler
sort of thing but infused with different
alcohols usually when you make an apple
cobbler a lot of people put like
cinnamon in it so I thought I'll use
fireball because that is a cinnamon
whiskey and on top of an apple cobbler a
lot of people put whipped cream or ice
cream and so I'm going the whipped cream
route I'm going to make my own whipped
cream that I'm also going to see what
happens when I try and add whipped vodka
to it in theory sounds like it could
definitely go either way could be great
or it could be awful like a Valentine's
Day date this recipe is gonna hopefully
be like your date loose whoa I three
apples we're gonna cut them up let's do
that roast gonna preheat our oven to 350
degrees
don't mess with my click like my ideal
date I need something sharp forgot but I
bought myself a box of knives that I
have yet to open because I couldn't find
a knife
Oh turns out they're extremely easy Joe
we're just gonna kind of try to cut them
great put them in this thing
BAM all three apples are kind of naked
and chopped up okay
next we're going to do is consult the
internet for information and guidance
now we're going to combine sugar flowers
and fireball and a every good
Valentine's Day date has liquor and eggs
one cup of flour oh I never buttered
that pan that's about cup of sugar
yay the bowl look terrible Ron Hey Oh
beautiful
there's a whole mess of shells in there
now we're going to add our cinnamon it
says add one tablespoon of cinnamon that
seems like a fair amount of cinnamon now
I mix it up until it looks like coarse
cornmeal according to specific are you
coarse cornmeal yet this was like cookie
dough and not fourscore milk I think I
put too much of the fireball in there
I'm gonna put more flour just see what
happens like my ideal date I'm gonna use
my hands is this coarse cornmeal like my
not so ideal date it is just so
Oh yet Oh this recipe is a lot like my
ideal date it forces you to wash your
hands numerous times throughout the
whole process
original topping over apple apples and
pour melted butter over the dish whoa
yes great I have a cup of melted butter
like my ideal relationship seemingly
really sweet but it'll kill you okay now
let's melt some butter oh that's gonna
be real bad like my ideal date it just
requires someone and paper towels to
clean up okay we're going to pour this
melted butter over this entire dish and
we're going to put it in a 350 degree
oven for a half hour this seems like def
soup oh great job team's orbit halfway
there let's take a break while our apple
cobbler cooks we are going to make our
homemade whipped cream for it so we're
going to use the same Bowl we're going
to clean it out to make our whipped
cream we need a cup of heavy cream and
we need a teaspoon of vanilla extract
but instead of vanilla extract I'm going
to use whipped cream flavored vodka BAM
and then we need a tablespoon of
confectioner's sugar and in you go then
we're just supposed to whip it together
until it makes whipped cream like my
ideal date it is more work for my arm
than I anticipated whip it together
until make stiff peaks like oh my ideal
days you get it
Oh Oh only starting to transform like my
ideal date if you put it enough work you
can change them Oh take a frame okay we
did it look Wow the apple cobbler
finishes that we're going to put this in
the refrigerator stay cold Oh goose is
eating the cream okay now it's
officially done as a spoiler secret I
turn the broiler on for the last like
minute of its cooking to make the top
really actually golden brown oh it's
beautiful and only slightly burned looks
a little weird you guys see edged it out
okay you can all see it I've been on
etsy too long so I'm going to make apple
cobbler in a mug I like things hat and
unpalatable some whipped cream on top oh
my God look at that that just looks like
it wait and look this is gonna be way
too hot to handle
like a JLo music video like my ideal
date it's not the worst it needs
something but it's fine for now
like my uncle day unexpected layers of
interesting textures there we go there
is my wobbly calmly Valentine's Day date
deserve and Norv any day they deserve
it's really not the worst thing in the
world I encourage you to experiment
something something about dating who
knows thanks for watching guys make sure
if you like to see you too give it a
thumbs
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel for more informative
life-changing content like what you've
seen today and leave a comment down
below waiting for Valentine's Day oh
that's interesting I don't know why I
was so daring whipped cream huh
no there's complete there it's heavy
cream I thought it was just like egg
whites and no it's just literally heavy
cream that you wish
oh no I'm thinking of oil you have to
eat this quick clean man please great
thank you action